it is interesting when you're in Europe
you're like oh this is like what
Disneyland is like
based off of in Vegas and [__] like that
yeah you know we have the culture here
it's just like yeah we have walkable
this is like the simulations yeah the
walkable cities are in Anaheim
California yeah Orlando Florida
exactly okay exactly they're very
walkable seats yes
um cobblestone stuff there's a couple
sets
yeah it's like the MGM or like Universal
Studios or whatever
that looks like Europe
I mean the walkable City in Anaheim
California The Cheesecake Factory looks
like Europe yes yes go there yeah
see look this has all different
countries
okay
yeah look at that look at Main Street
man
that's what Europe looks like yep
honestly Yep this is Italy
literally it is
that's what they sound like that's
Venice
that's actually bang on actually a bunch
of stupid Americans in a big ass gondola
uh Kanye getting ahead
Connie got hit in a gondola yeah what no
I didn't see that what you didn't see
that cue it did he got banned from like
all boats in Venice or something because
he got head he's got top
how did you not see this dude I've seen
a lot but I didn't see this oh my God
was it a private tour this was man you
weren't even trying to hide it I know
top dude top down huh huh he's top boy
yeah right there head in a gondola is
crazy that's not a gondola though that's
like a private hire
yeah what if it was just like on like a
like a public tour
oh like one of those Amsterdam tours
where it's 120 tourists in there that's
wild
that is wild I mean that that you know
I I want to say there's a rumor in high
school because we had a high school trip
to Disneyland there was a rumor that
someone got ahead on
The Haunted Mansion ride okay which
one's that it's the one where you kind
of like
it's like two of you sit and you go
around like a little graveyard yeah I'm
picturing someone like like the funniest
rides to get head on I think Tower of
Terror would be [__] hilarious
[Laughter]
like you're not sure if you came or not
or if you're just like stomach went up
and you're
so which one's the Haunted Mansion you
go in these little bucket type seats
that you're kind of covered on each side
oh yeah okay it's a rapid ride I don't
know
if you could even like get your dick out
in time
I don't think it's very fast
It's a small world that would be a
little bit [__] up that is a [__]
assault charge I mean anywhere in
Disneyland if you're on a list but yeah
small world is special that one
especially yeah oh Matterhorn that
that's just a challenge in and of itself
is that the log ride that's no that's
the one that goes through the mountain
with the yeti
uh that ride was made in 1960 and they
haven't changed it oh yeah it's like the
wooden one a borderline they're like
it's supposed to be like no it looks
like it's wood doesn't it no no no okay
it's uh it's on like first of all the
the track for it
is still from 1960. it's just two steel
pipes yeah yeah yeah
the thing that's [__] up about this
right is your head is looking this way
and then it just
I think it's not what you're talking
about it did not plan for your head to
turn so you're like oh
look at your [__] disc in your neck
because they like didn't have physics
fully figured out by it no by then yeah
you know the whole round what year was
it 62 it was like 63 or some [__] yeah I
like this ride they're still you know
like researching the laws of motion at
that point yeah you know
so if you somehow really sure like they
were like yeah just crank the yeah just
turn it left the track has to go that
way right yeah just crank it
yeah
yeah I think in getting ahead on this
ride would be that'd be an achievement
man
so you're you're happy to be home
yeah yeah I am yeah I had a great time
it was fun the wedding was great
um Sicily was nice
oh I DJ'd at my friend's wedding oh so
he he told me he's like bring your USB
and I'm like okay like is there gonna be
like a DJ set up or something like that
and he's like yeah we're we're gonna
have a DJ at the wedding and I was like
okay
so I wasn't really sure like how that
would work right so I get there
and uh the day of the wedding comes in
I'm like is this still happening he's
like yeah we're just gonna ask him if
you can like go on
for the last hour
and um
you know like
I don't know wedding DJs
I don't think they like to share
no and especially like I don't know this
dude was just not down for that and I go
up and I'm like I have my USB and I'm
like hey he wants me to take over and he
was like no just tell me what you want
me to play
and I was like oh [__] okay so then I
had to ask the groom to basically tell
the guy like okay it's my turn
and he was not happy ah at all
and uh he was like I've been he's like
I've been hired to play
like
why can't I play
artisan
and my friend was like I'm paying you
still we're just like we want to use the
equipment for the last hour oh man an
Italian bureaucracy right there but no
you pay me pay me I play I played the
four hours I play yeah
and uh so then he just stepped aside and
just was like just defeated that's
hulking sulking and then would like
scream at me like
was like be careful with the equipment I
know and then I would like you know
someone pass me a drink like no alcohol
around there
[Music]
I get it
and I was careful with the equipment
and uh and then my the one of the dudes
this got one of my friends friends good
friend that I met he's an MC
and a really good MC he spent like
multiple years like doing it in Greece
and and uh [__] like Ibiza and [__]
like that just
like like he was like a DJ slash MC but
like his talents were in mcing like just
getting the crowd like hyped up oh and
so he came on the mic as I was playing
and he was like he's just saying all
this crazy [__] he's got a British
accent uh so he's like saying all this
slick [__] yeah it's not gonna sound
good if I say it but you know
I'm gonna try
all right well what oh damn I feel like
I'm listening to BBC One yeah go
my Ravens my misbehaviors how we feeling
tonight right oh everyone goes [__]
crazy
I know it doesn't sound cool when I say
but when he says it sounds cool it's a
cool phrase yeah
my misbehavior that's kind of that's I
know it's sick all right all right you
do it or my Rave is my misbehaving yeah
exactly how are we feeling tonight yeah
exactly
and then he's on one right so he's like
cat he's like feeding off the crowd's
energy and they're going crazy
and so then he goes he said something
about how we're on because the last guy
was [__]
and he's standing there right beside us
and apparently he was not happy about
that you didn't know she just didn't
turn I didn't know I didn't hear that
because I was like in when my headphones
trying to like figure out the next song
or whatever so I didn't hear that but
then the next day my friend was like
yeah we went and like you know closed
out with him afterwards
and he was not happy about that at all
so I felt really bad
really bad